the former IMF chief dominique
strauss-kahn has gone on trial in France
accused of helping to procure sex
workers for an alleged prostitution ring
Douglas yet from the American University
of Paris spoke to us about to mr.
strauss-kahn's political rise and fall
and warning there's flash photography
coming up this was a person who had both
great intelligence had become an
inspector de phenols that is a member of
the technocratic elite and had a
personal life with a famous French
television personality a woman who read
the news and did documentary films and
who brought him into the milieu of if
you will the Paris elite so he was
someone with a foot in both worlds um
his rise to the Socialist Party like
many of his generation had been forged
during the meet Rhonda era and around
him they had formed a faction of people
who I think would be called outside is
neoliberal but he was a strand of the
French Socialist Party who was
interested in implementing the kinds of
reforms we tend to associate with
Sarkozy in fact um when Nicolas Sarkozy
presented himself for re-election and
people were posed to ask them who they
think what socialist should challenge
Nicolas Sarkozy a growing number of
people in the polls show Dominique
strauss-kahn he became the front-runner
for quite a long time and it was all of
a sudden by surprise that he was
arrested in New York for us he told
about jello for the the case that the
charges that would eventually brought
the criminal charges the trial of
Dominique strauss-kahn and those are the
events that led Francois Hollande to
become president in fact and so after a
small while I think there was an effort
to try to sound the waters and see if a
dominique strauss-kahn could come back
not only because um he has an enormous
number of competencies he had been
director of the IMF for example he had
been Minister of Finance or France but
also for so
disappointed with francois hollande